et diplômes à la main sourire aux lèvres
devant leurs camarades de promotion et
leurs parents près d'une cinquantaine
d'enfants de plaisir et ses environs se
voient récompensés de leurs efforts ils
ont participé durant l'été à un stage de
trois jours avec les sapeurs-pompiers
plaisir wa un stage en forme de rêve
pour beaucoup d'entre eux et pour se
mettre dans la peau d'un professionnel
la grande échelle où on a fait
on a fait une fois mon affaire le
bataille d'eau et c'était c'était bien
mais ce que monsieur salle et nous a
arrosé voilà on a appris les numéros
d'appel d'urgence
on est monté à une grande échelle à 30
mètres on a fait du rappel on est allé
dans un mais par houcine centenaire
virades dans le noir mis en place par la
mairie de plaisir depuis 15 ans en
partenariat avec le centre secours local
ces stages estivaux ont surtout une
portée pédagogique respect efforts
physiques notamment permettent de mieux
répercuter certains enseignements
le premier objectif c'est de faire un
lien entre la population de plaisir et
des environs avec le métier de sapeur
pompier pour que la population comprenne
dès le plus jeune âge une omission le
après un autre objectif c'est de
reprendre nous dans notre rôle de
prévention
c'est de leur apprendre de leur faire
passer des messages de prévention sur
les numéros de téléphone d'urgence sur
les premiers gestes réalisés lors d'une
intervention d'urgence de nouvelles
sessions sont prévues l'été prochain les
inscriptions débuteront en juin
d'ici là les jeunes stagiaires pourront
diffuser leurs connaissances à l'école